[Music]
the countdown is officially on to the
world premiere of Georgina miles twins a
source tells et the two little Clooney's
could arrive any day now this is very
exciting now George is clearly thinking
the same thing that they'll come any day
because he just blew off a big award
ceremony to say by his life sighs I'm
sorry that I can't be with you all
tonight in Yerevan I really would have
been there but if I came there and my
wife had twins while I was there I could
never come home we've been told the
official due date is June 4th and with a
source in London saying I'm all is
expected to give birth early
you can't blame George for not making
the 8 and a half hour flight to attend
the Aurora prize for awakening humanity
event in Armenia the 56 year old dad to
be sent this video message instead
United we can make a difference it's not
just ok to take care of yourself that we
are as successful as the least fortunate
among us right now George and Amal are
on baby lockdown here at their home in
Berkshire England the couple spent a
reported 16 million renovating the five
and a half acre Island estate which is
said to include 18 security cameras and
nanny's quarters and an editing suite so
George can work from homes you guys have
names everything picked out or my wife
said I can't name them Casa and amigos
that's the one thing I'm not allowed to
do well just three weeks ago Amal threw
a surprise birthday party for George
besties Cindy Crawford and Randy Gerber
showed up and one gift was pink and blue
cos amigos onesies
[Music]
you